there so now i'm just a little bit tired  yeah it will be even longer to go to  sochi  uh i guess uh and what  maybe i should the last question about  today i guess you followed  um what happened with  uh the result of kasparov and what's  your  take on that i mean like you are  certainly not expecting  such results no  i mean being old is tough okay  yeah but yeah i i think  it's just a case of everything going  going going wrong  uh in one day so i cannot see it  happening again so i really hope  i really hope that they will play some  good games tomorrow yeah  we all do hope for that and uh okay  thanks  thanks a lot for joining and good luck  for tomorrow  thank you bye